warne
bonsoir nous sommes jeudi 5 novembre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale accompagnés de nos
invités mais aussi des journalistes de
la rédaction
on commence vite avec les titres de
cette édition après la pédagogie la
répression aujourd'hui sur la plupart
des lignes du transilien
de nombreux contrôles pour lutter contre
la fraude ne pas payer son titre de
transport représente un manque à gagner
de 2 63 millions d'euros par an pour la
sncf ces contrôles lance une opération
d'envergure qui va durer tout au long du
mois et c'était aujourd'hui la première
journée nationale contre le harcèlement
alors a lieu désormais chaque année le
premier jeudi après les vacances de la
toussaint
un numéro vert est mis en place le 30 20
des opérations de sensibilisation
viennent aussi d'être mené exemple tout
à l'heure dans un lycée de versailles et
enfin la ville de trappes qui propose du
9 au 28 novembre une opération baptisée
moi raciste
expositions projections débats et
actions organisées en partenariat
notamment avec leur allure ap
nous en parlerons tout à l'heure avec
nos invités et pour commencer cette
information l'ancien député européen
philippe de villiers était hier soir à
versailles venu donner une conférence au
théâtre montansier pour présenter son
livre le moment est venu de dire ce que
j'ai vu un ouvrage dans lequel l'ancien
président du conseil général de vendée
par le librement et s'assume en
conservateur souverainiste le
rendez-vous a fait salle comble mais la
presse n'était pas conviée philippe de
villiers ayant accepté de répondre aux
questions de son lectorat mais pas à
celles des journalistes et 7,5 pour cent
c'est le taux de fraude est estimée au
quotidien en ile-de-france sur 3
millions de voyageurs sur le réseau sncf
un manque à gagner de 63 millions
d'euros contre lequel la sncf entend
bien lutté tout au long du mois de
novembre
différentes opérations 0 fraude sont
prévues dans toutes les grandes gares
parisiennes mais aussi en banlieue comme
ce matin à la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines où étaient mélanie gauthier et
sephora namani 8 heures du matin gare de
saint quentin en yvelines 30 contrôleurs
et 10 agents de la sécurité de la sncf
sont déployés pour l'opération zéro
fraude
après un mois d'octobre consacré à la
prévention place aux contrôles contrôler
les gens qui ont menti de transport pour
leur dire qu'on est là aussi pour eux
pour continuer à prendre un type de
transport ce qui est important et
de régulariser toutes les personnes qui
sont démunis de transport alors soit
parce qu'elles ont eu un problème avant
de monter dans le train soit parce que
décide de prendre le type de transport
manière à ce que tout le monde soit
contrôlée et travail voyage de manière
équitable à saint-quentin-en-yvelines 27
mille voyageurs empruntent chaque jour
la gare des usagers qui ne comprennent
pas tous l'utilité de ces contrôles
comme par hasard aujourd'hui je vais car
dans dans l'aude veste en fait j'ai mis
la mauvaise reste doit payer 50 euros
mais si je présente ma carte voilà au
service clientèle ça va se faire
rembourser donc ça me rassure c'est
important je trouve va sinon en b
pourquoi les autres ils payent pas c'est
simple on peut pas se rendre sur depuis
le travail en temps et en heure et s'est
du coup ça bloque tout le monde
puis bien en soi si on fraude il suffit
juste d'attendre une heure ici qui
partent et puis après on peut s'en aller
quoi en ile-de-france le taux de fraude
quotidien concerne deux cent vingt mille
voyageurs alors la sncf a décidé de
lancer un plan de lutte anti-fraude avec
un déploiement de 400 bornes de
validation supplémentaire et des agents
d'escale assermentés qui pourraient
contrôler les 2016 le manque à gagner
qui correspond à la fraude sur l'île de
france 63 millions d'euros par an donc
on peut évidemment envisager que ce que
la perception ne serait ce que d'une
partie de 63 millions d'euros c'est une
capacité d'investissement pour améliorer
effectivement le confort la propreté la
qualité d'accueil et d'accès aux d'accès
au train par exemple sachez qu'en cas de
non présentation de votre titre de
transport
vous encourez une amende de 50 au nom au
harcèlement à l'école c'était le mot
d'ordre de cette première journée
nationale contre le harcèlement
le gouvernement lance une grande
campagne de prévention impliquant les
collégiens mais aussi les lycéens au
lycée marie-curie de versailles l'action
a été ciblée sur le harcèlement 2.0 qui
sévit sur les réseaux sociaux et aussi
sur internet
regardez ce reportage de fanny bourdon
comment éviter le cyber harcèlement dit
le harcèlement 2.0 une quarantaine de
lycéens du département a abordé la
question au lycée marie-curie de
versailles à l'occasion de la première
journée nationale contre le harcèlement
à l'école experts associations et élèves
ont pu échanger sur le sujet c'est
important qu'ils aient des journées
comme ça parce qu'on ne vend on a
vraiment l'impression dans un choc
générationnel entre ces générations
surtout sur les questions du numérique
on a beaucoup parlé des questions du
numérique parce que c'est surtout là que
se fait le
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup discuté de
l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux
là on vient de faire un test sur notre
réputation donc la réputation qu'on a
sur le web aujourd'hui utilisée quand
même pas les employeurs l'harcèlement
concernerait environ 700 mille élèves
chaque année soit 7 % des collégiens et
3 % des lycéens un phénomène accentué
avec les réseaux sociaux je pense que
c'est quelque chose de très fréquents
comme les gens ils ont ils sont cachés
derrière des ordinateurs et sentait
enfin ils sentent protégés et donc ça
leur permet facilement d'insulter les
gens gratuitement
l'objectif de la journée était de
sensibiliser les jeunes à ces problèmes
pour vivre à l'école grâce au
développement d'un oued plus citoyen le
développement des nouvelles technologies
technologies les évolutions sociétales
font que bien évidemment nous sommes
confrontés dans les établissements
quotidien à des difficultés difficile à
maîtriser d'ailleurs parce qu'elles se
poursuivent aussi le soir à la maison et
dure un peu 24 heures sur 24 avec des
nouvelles technologies et les problèmes
inhérents à ces nouvelles technologies
donc il arrive fréquemment que des
élèves soient victimes de cyber
harcèlement ou de problèmes sur facebook
cela chat et cetera la solution ou
harcèlement à l'école et d'en parler un
numéro vert a été mis en place par le
gouvernement le 30 20 et nous recevons
ce soir en plateau à lire rabais
maire-adjoint de trappes et thérèse loi
secrétaire du mrap de saint quentin en
yvelines
bonsoir à vous deux alors je rappelle le
rap c'est le mouvement contre le racisme
et pour l'amitié entre les peuples c'est
une association française qui a été
créée en 1949 alors vous êtes ici pour
nous parler de l'événement moi raciste
qui se déroule du 9 au 25 novembre
rattrape avec des expositions des
projections des débats et des actions
pour sensibiliser les jeunes contre le
racisme c'est la première fois que cet
événement est organisé à trappes
absolument à l'initiative du mouvement
contre le racisme et pour l'amitié entre
les peuples qui a proposé à la commune
de trappes en particulier au service
jeunesse
l'organisation d'une campagne de
sensibilisation de dialogue avec les
jeunes pour les alerter sur la
thématique évidemment du racisme du
vivre ensemble d'être capable de lever
les préjugés les identifier ensemble le
racisme des victimes on en est aussi
parfois auteurs c'est un peu comme le
harcèlement dont on a tout à l'heure
j'ai eu un petit extrait donc on a bien
volontiers souhaité collaborer avec le
mrap
leur équipe et ça se traduira on y
reviendra par la mise à disposition
d'une exposition qui va circuler sur les
trois espaces jeunesse du 9 au 28
novembre par également toute une
campagne de photographies prises par les
jeunes qui vont se prendre en photo
pendant chaque espace jeunesse et
ensuite partager ses photographies pour
essayer dé lire ensemble on va terminer
par la projection d'un film et je
laisserais évidemment le mrap ont parlé
mieux que moi alors donc cette
exposition qui s'intitule racisme
discrimination comprendre pour agir il
ya neuf pas nous elle a été elle est
partie d'une d'une revue qui est sorti
au niveau de l'indicé c'était une bande
dessinée voilà et qui était une
publication officielle de la communauté
européenne
en 1998 alors effectivement cette cette
bd a été reprise par le mrap de province
d'une province avec le national aussi et
ils ont monté cette exposition
l'exposition itinérante donc il alors de
la france effectivement elle tourne
puisque lé taux national et on peut on
peut la demander
effectivement ce set
cette exposition va aller sur les trois
centres jeunesse
donc ça va commencer le 9 et ça se
terminera le 28 le 28 il y aura un débat
nous allons organiser avec des jeunes
militants de
du mrap nationale qui vont venir qui ont
l'habitude de parler aux jeunes
alors justement cette expression fin
c'est la première fois qu'elle vient ici
on les attrape
pourquoi vous êtes dire voilà on va la
faire venir ce qu'il y avait un contexte
spécifique est ce que vous dites c'est
le moment d'agir où je crois que le
contexte malheureusement il n'est pas du
tout local il est plutôt nationale on a
multiplié question de déclarations qui
sont pas forcément le fait qu'on ne
rencontre pas toujours uniquement sur le
terrain on a des responsables politiques
de premier plan qui parle de race
blanche qui exacerbe les sentiments
racistes chez les individus qui essayent
également d'en tirer quelques dividendes
électoraux
nous on pense comme moi comme nuls mais
comme citoyen également que les c'est
justement ce qui s'exprime et qui
véhiculent des thèses racistes plus ou
moins de façon plus ou moins explicite
par les seuls dans le décor général et
ne pas permettre notamment aux enfants
et aux jeunes de d'avoir en tête les
grands éléments qui font de l'amitié
entre les peuples
le fait que l'identité individuelle ne
se font pas que sur la couleur de peau
les origines lesquelles se fonde sur
bien d'autres aspects c'est absolument
nécessaire et donc il faut être capable
d'expliquer aux plus jeunes les
mécanismes qui aime qui amène à
reproduire des clichés racistes sur ses
voisins sur ceux qui cohabitent dans la
même espace dans la même ville et
essayer de les déconstruire plus que
jamais je pense que la période justifie
que ce type d'initiative soit mené en
particulier en direction des jeunes
santé par exemple
cette situation alors effectivement le
mrap a toujours lutté contre toutes
formes de discriminations est bon
souvent les jeunes ne comprennent pas
très bien ce que c'est que le racisme
facilement vous êtes raciste août
bref faut être comme ça mais bon
finalement il faut qu'ils aient aussi
travaillé pour leur demander de
travailler un peu plus à fond puisque
bon il y aller il ya des préjugés les
stéréotypes et tout ça et des fois ils
font pas bien la différence entre être
sûr qu'elle sur quels éléments ne font
pas la différence où il se trompe il est
important de leur rappeler que quand ils
s'interpellent entre eux déjà et puis
bon c'est vrai que trappe
c'est quand même une ville où il ya
beaucoup de diversité donc c'est sûr que
non plus 50 nationalisée ça va très vite
avec les jeunes
donc voilà donc ce sont des petits des
citoyens des jeunes citoyens
donc je pense qu'il faut déjà travailler
avec eux on verra ce que cela va donner
mais bon je pense que nous
personnellement c'est vrai qu'on n'est
pas habitué à avoir
mais les militants de trappes de terrain
puisque nous avons plutôt une exposition
pour le droit des étrangers alors mais
là et puis nous n'avons pas aussi de
gens qui viennent pour nous dire voilà
je suis victime de racisme on en a eu
très peu et parce que nous avons des
juristes se faire national et ainsi de
suite ils peuvent nous donner un coup de
main mais je pense que les gens pour eux
les jeunes avoir les papiers et de
pouvoir conserver cette régularisation
c'est tellement important
donc c'est là dessus surtout quand on
vient nous rencontrer à la permanence
maintenant c'est vrai qu'on se d'un
talent et je pense que nous avons les
outils aux marques nationales nous avons
aussi des militants qui sont plus jeunes
et qui sont habitués à aller dans les
glisser dans les collèges pour parler
justement avec les jeunes
mais justement fin à la trappe donc le
sais tu sois là c'est une bloom qui est
très cosmopolite il ya beaucoup de
mixité sociale
on pourrait dire justement voilà les
gens il y a moins de racisme dans ces
quartiers où finalement il ya beaucoup
de questions elle a plus de fraternité
vous pouvez dans d'autres communes parce
que déjà on est plus fraternelle quand
on est issu de milieux modestes c'est
une réalité observée par tous et mais ça
veut pas dire qu'il ya pas de phénomène
de racisme évidemment entre les
individus d'une même classe sociale
mais le fait que ce qu'on soit une ville
cosmopolite ne protège pas du progrès
des idées racistes les thèses de
l'extrême droite notamment
j'en veux pour preuve d'ailleurs
l'émergence du vote d'extrême droite sur
la commune de trappes
on a eu deux européennes partis du front
national et qui arrivait première liste
sur la ville de trappes c'est une
élection particulière la participation
n'était pas très élevé mais ça montre
bien qu'on peut avoir de plus en plus
d'électeurs qui en désespoir de cause
parce que leur situation personnelle
parfois les désespère considère que le
problème c'est l'étranger où c'est celui
qui est différent
donc l'objectif d'une action comme celle
là en particulier auprès des jeunes
c'est de faire savoir que qu'on habite
tel ou tel quartier de trappes qu'on est
telle ou telle couleur de peau qu'on est
telle ou telle origine soit issue tel ou
tel pays ou pas qu'on soit né en france
je suis français je suis également
marocain mes parents sont tous les deux
marocains d'origine
imagine que ce n'est pas votre cas et
pourtant ça nous empêche pas de nous
considérer dans la fraternité l'amitié
et travailler ensemble pour essayer
d'améliorer le quotidien des habitants
de la ville d'auch travers ces valeurs
là il faut les partager
faut pas les garder pour soi quand on a
eu la chance d'en hériter et ce type
d'action permet en faisant en sorte que
les jeunes dialogue entre eux déjà les
jeunes de trappes puissent discuter
entre eux dans chaque espace jeunesse on
va engager de dialogue autour des
justement les conférences qui sont a
prévu la vraiment des échanges possède
ces fameuses planches qui vont être
exposés c'est un prétexte à l'échangé la
discussion l'objectif n'est pas de
passer devant être regarder un dessin
l'objectif c'est vraiment de
s'interroger sur telle ou telle
interpellation que le dessin propose aux
jeunes qui les observons donc c'est
d'engager dialogue dans chaque espace
jeunesse on ne discutait juste avant sur
l'opportunité d'élargir un peu les
horaires pour permettre à des classes de
venir dans les lycées ou du collège des
lycées ou des collège de trappes de
venir travailler avec leurs enseignants
autour de cette exposition
et puis ensuite débattre autour du film
qui va être diffusé le 25 novembre et
discuter également avec leur père qui
viendront militants du mrap qui
viendront d'autres départements pour
avoir un vrai dialogue constructif
encore une fois il s'agit pas juste de
dire le racisme c'est pas bien
il faut comprendre en quoi chacun
parfois peut véhiculer des thèses
racistes et comment on peut contribuer
dans son action quotidienne à diminuer
le degré de tension qui peut exister
entre les individus et j'insiste sur un
point particulier parce que dans votre
question c'est est induit et on en a
parlé ce soir mais la discrimination le
sentiment d'être discriminées ce qui
implique qu est-ce qui parfois amène des
jeunes à tout confondre à confondre
assises et le sentiment d'être
discriminées d'un sentiment extrêmement
prégnante chez les jeunes de trappes que
je rencontre quasiment à chacune de mes
de mes entretiens de mes échanges réunit
régulièrement des groupes de jeunes
trappistes pour échanger sur leurs
problèmes du quotidien et la façon
d'améliorer la vie à trappes est très
régulièrement que ce soit pour l'accès
aux stages dès la troisième vous voyez
ça commence très tôt pour des jeunes que
ce soit pour l'accès à de
l'apprentissage pour entrer dans une
école et surtout pour trouver un métier
même quand on est diplômé et même quand
on est diplômé du supérieur
vous avez un vrai sentiment d'être
discriminées qui a un sentiment vérifier
par tous les travaux des sociologues des
associations antiracistes et là dessus
il faut aussi qu'on puisse travailler
collectivement
il faut aussi être capable d'armer les
jeunes pour affronter un monde qui part
pour avaler discriminer notamment le
monde du travail vient merci à vous et
en tout cas d'être venu en plateau pour
nous alors je le rappelle donc moi
raciste l'exposition enfin tout ce qu'il
ya autour c'est d'une main 19 au samedi
28 novembre
alors il ya plein d exposition à
l'espace jeunes anatole-france à
l'espace jeunes le village est aussi
respect jean paul langevin à trappes et
la projection du film documentaire la
ligne de couleur tu aura lieu au cinéma
le grenier à sel mercredi 25 novembre à
14 heures nous n'irons pas merci en tout
cas vous dois vous dire que je ne sais
où j'ai raté mon voile alors n'hésitez
pas à vous y rendre et leur appel
conférence est plein de débat autour de
cette question et nous vous en parlions
hier dans le journal nous sommes en
plein milieu de la campagne de
vaccination à voisins le bretonneux des
séances de vaccination gratuite sur
rendez vous auront lieu cet après midi
et jusqu'à demain cette année ce sont
184 vie si noah qui viendront se faire
vacciner contre le virus de la grippe
une opération organisée par la ville
tous les ans à la proche de l'hiver
grâce à la participation bénévole de
médecins en écoute d'ailleurs leurs
recommandations donc on le fait surtout
chez les gens à risque les gens âgés
depuis longtemps les gens risquent de
diabétiques asthmatiques même les
enfants en fait on le fait aussi
beaucoup aux enfants ils pigeons qui
sont aux utilités les gens qui veulent
ne pas manquer le travail par exemple
c'est important que ça vacciner pour la
grippe une grippe c'est
ça peut être bénins chez jean
exclusivement qui ont des défenses
immunitaires qui se soit clic ce qui
sont corrects mais c'est des gens à
risque si c'était ça peut être ça peut
être mortel se prémunir ses hygiène
demain parfait quand les gens tous il
faut plus se tous effectivement ça mange
tout sur sa main pareil pour le mouchage
il faut se moucher et puis après c'est
la ville des mains même si maintenant
les bouchard se ressourceront papiers
sont jetables
mais si la main après le mouchage n'est
pas lavé ses porteurs de virus tout ce
qui est mouchage tout et puis
effectivement lavage de mains c'est
important et on passe aux sports à
présent vous le savez l'euro de football
2016 sera organisé en france du 10 juin
au 10 juillet c'est quand même bientôt
24 équipes participeront à la
compétition et les yvelines pourrait
servir de comptes de base à 2 sélections
nationales la france restera évidemment
à clairefontaine et une équipe étrangère
pourrait s'installer à versailles la
cité royale a été sélectionné par l'uefa
regardez ce reportage de nickel et demi
d'euros et jérémy tessa dare une équipe
nationale pourrait prendre ses quartiers
à versailles pour l'euro de football
l'uefa organisatrice du tournoi a retenu
la cité royale pour accueillir une
sélection juin prochain la commune
yvelinoise est une habituée des grandes
compétitions dans les étudiants 98 pour
la coupe du monde une équipe qui était
la hollande
on a fait en avril l'angleterre pour le
rugby pour la coupe du monde aussi de
2007 dans le dossier présenté à l'uefa
deux sites
on retrouve le stade mont boron d'une
capacité de 6000 places et l' hôtel du
trianon palace de versailles
notre terrain est quand même très
intéressant et une qualité il est bien
fermée quand on veut le faire mais on
peut accueillir du public il ya tout un
tas d'atouts et puis la capacité
hôtelière de versailles est de qualité
surtout sur un autre équipement qu'il
trianon donc l'uefa a qualifié le site
autour de ces deux aspects la qualité de
nos terrains et de metric mans et la
capacité hôtelière pour accueillir une
sélection étrangère pendant l'euro la
ville de versailles à rénover le stade
de mauron coût total de l'opération une
centaine de milliers d'euros
on a aménagé une salle et sous les
tribunes
donc on a réaménagé de façon à ce que
m'en faire une salle de presse donc moi
une salle de réception pour le club bras
à l'entraînement de presse et puis des
aménagements de vestiaire c'est pas
grand chose mais c'est important
ces dernières semaines la roumanie la
pologne la turquie les émissaires de
l'équipe d'italie aurait visité les
installations de versailles
les sélections devraient annoncer leur
choix avant la fin de l'année et en
parlant de rôles affaire tombe mal
ajustement sept mois de l'événement
karim benzema a été déféré devant la
justice dans la sphère du chantage à la
sextape de mathieu valbuena l'attaquant
du real de madrid a été placé hier en
garde à vue dans les locaux de la police
judiciaire de versailles
il aurait reconnu être intervenu dans le
chantage fait à mathieu valbuena ce que
son avocat des mots selon le procureur
il a été mise en examen pour complicité
et tentative de chantage
l'international français est placé sous
contrôle judiciaire avec l'interdiction
d'entrer en contact de quelques façons
ce soit avec la victime et les autres
mises en examen
il n'a pas été convoqué avec dans la
cession des bleus par dix nations ni
mathieu valbuena d'ailleurs pour les
matches du match amical contre
l'allemagne le vendredi 13 novembre
et comme chaque jeudi vous en avez
l'habitude maintenant c'est la chronique
sport avec notre journaliste est mutuel
et demi d'euros alors bon sens mais
qu'elle soit vous allez vous présenter
les rendez vous à ne pas manquer ce
week-end dans lé département fectivement
je vais vous donner quelques idées de
sorties sportives pour ce week-end nous
allons tout d'abord prendre la direction
des parcs et yvelinois on jouera sous
lequel un match de basket qui leur sera
à n'en pas douter très serré trappe
rosso vineuil ce samedi à 20 heures au
gymnase paul mallet pour nous parler de
cette rencontre nous recevons chaque
niche il est le président du club de
trappes
bonjour bonsoir je disais précédemment
le match ce samedi s'annonce très serré
et très compliqué pour trappe
oui sans doute parce que nous avons une
équipe
nouvelle comme j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de le dire et qui est encore en rodage
cependant on en enregistre quand même
trois bonnes sorties les trois dernières
qui se sont révélés être des victoires
notamment contre le deuxième de 25
points c'est pas bien c'est pas
négligeable et notamment également en
coupe de france contre gennevilliers où
là aussi on a gagné à l'extérieur ce qui
n'est pas mal et donc nous allons avoir
maintenant ce match de samedi contre
effectivement vineuil que nous
connaissions l'avions déjà rencontré
dernière et ça a été un match
effectivement serré j'espère qu'on va
confirmer les l'homogénéité de l'équipe
cette fois-ci et puis que ça devrait
aller mais bien sûr c'est encore fragile
donc je le rappelle pour les
téléspectateurs qui ne vous suivent pas
tous de tous les week-ends trap a très
mal commencé la saison avec trois
défaites
maintenant vous vous reprenez
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui fait la
différence sur ces derniers matchs est
ce que le collectif prend eh bien oui on
a on a renouvelé notre équipe à 70%
ce qui fait que quelle que soit la
valeur intrinsèque de chaque individu
et bien il y a un certain temps
nécessaire pour roder le collectif
ce qui explique nos premières défaites
et en plus pas contre les meilleures
équipes
ce qui n'était pas notre faveur mais il
faut dire aussi que nous avons eu un
blessé
mounir qui était dit marc 25 points par
match en qui marque 25 points par match
qui est un défenseur tout à fait
important également est qui et qui a été
absent pendant ce mois et qui revient et
qui revient à la compétition
voilà et qui revient à la compétition et
puis d'autre part et bien je peux dire
aussi que nos amis joey et puis
également sous la direction je dirais de
notre nouveau meneur a argué qu'ils
devaient être ici je le remplace parce
que ils jouent ce soir ils jouent ce
soir de francs 1 coupe de france encore
et ce match du coup ce week-end contre
vineuil est-ce qu'il est primordial pour
la suite de la saison
est-ce qu'il faut absolument remporter
je dirais comme maintenant nous nous
espérons remporter chaque rencontre
pour nous la victoire est recherché on a
on a malgré tout l'ambition d'être dans
le haut du tableau même si nous avons
mal démarré mais pour des raisons que
j'ai expliqué il faut rappeler que
l'année dernière avec un renouvellement
moindre de l'équipe
il avait fallu attendre le mois de
janvier pour voir l'équipe se roder et
gagné tous ses matches dans l'équipe est
rodée
dès à présent et de l'équipe semble
rôder le sera ensemble le relais semble
rodée dès à présent donc on a quand même
ma deux mois d'avant ce là la question
quel est votre pronostic sur le match de
vineuil à lutter de trappes victoire de
trappes large victoire de trappes
si nous jouons comme les deux derniers
matches large victoire mais rien n'est
moins sûr parce qu'encore une fois
vintage est une bonne équipe et je ne je
ne sais pas quel sera l'intégration de
mounir par exemple temps dans cette
équipe qui re alors qu'il revient de
blessure c'est toujours un peu fragile
on suivra avec attention merci les
passer sur ce bateau je le rappelle le
match entre vignes et rap est programmée
ce samedi à 20 heures au gymnase paul
mallet je pense qu'il y aura du
spectacle sommes tout à fait et après le
basket on passe au ballon ovale on
jouera en fédérale 3 l'équipe de rugby
de versailles jouera ce week-end en
championnat les versailles et 7e de la
poule 2 de fédérale 3 recevront dans
leur stade de porchefontaine l'équipe de
courbevoie quatrième du classement
vous l'aurez compris le match s'annonce
compliqué pour les yvelinois l'enjeu est
double sur cette rencontre
versailles veut remonter au classement
et intégrer le top 4 mais ils veulent
aussi rebondir après leur défaite de la
semaine dernière contre pithiviers match
devrait donc être très tendu avec du
suspense je sais que vous adorez ça cela
fera ses vrais mutuelle j'adore les
matches accrochés et ceux qui devront
aussi justement s'accrocher ce sont les
coureurs de la force royal une
compétition programmée ce week-end dans
les yvelines
et oui il faudra s'accrocher florennes
d'autant plus que la météo s'annonce
maussade pour ce week-end la troisième
édition de la course royal est
programmée ce dimanche au départ de la
pièce d'eau des suisses à versailles au
programme une course de 10 km l'autre de
20 kilomètres des compétitions pour les
enfants et de la marche nordique
les participants ont donc le choix
l'arrivée est programmée au gymnase
descartes font-elles fleury plus de 200
participants devraient prendre le départ
de la course si vous voulez vous
inscrire florin il reste quelques places
michaël vous me connaissez si bien
pourquoi pas un petit 20 km et côté on
vous retrouve lundi pour le service
sport quel sera le programme
le programme sera chargé comme tous les
lundis nous recevrons notamment le
boxeur derrière voir ahmed el moussaoui
en ce sens nous parlerons de son combat
contre l'australien jeff hawn classée
27e mondiale en l'australie à brisbane
il y aura également le j'ai testé boxe
avec le même ahmed el moussaoui on l
écoute on regarde un extrait
vous avez peut-être lu avoir un petit
peu mal
un petit peu mal en tout cas c'est un
programme alléchant et j'ai déjà hâte de
vous voir boxer lundi c'est la fin de
cette édition merci de nous avoir suivis
demain vous avez rendez vous avec
wilfrid errishi pour une nouvelle
édition du 7 8 le journal nous
reviendrons notamment sur le conseil
communautaire de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et sur
l'organisation du département dans le
cadre du projet du grand paris quant à
moi il ne me reste plus qu'à vous
souhaiter un bon week-end je vous
retrouve lundi pour une nouvelle édition
du 7 8 le journal très bonne soirée